[Música]
há 20 anos na cidade do interior do
ceará
uma senhora muito meiga do cabelo
completamente branco teve um derrame
esse derrame deixou ela camada por
alguns meses ela teve muitas dores e
feridos muito graves na pele
pouco tempo depois mesmo com todo o
esforço da família
essa senhora veio a falecer essa senhora
não teve acesso aos melhores tratamentos
possíveis nem sequer era possível porque
como levar os melhores tratamentos para
lá com o interior do ceará
nem sequer era possível saber que
tratamentos eram esses
como saber de tudo que está acontecendo
no mundo estando no interior do ceará
essa senhora era a minha avó minha boca
nisso ea minha história o ciclo da minha
vida que eu vi hoje começou naquele dia
porque foi naquele dia que eu decidi que
eu seria se dentista e eu nasci pra isso
e um esforço a cada dia
por isso eu tentei várias dificuldades
para buscar a minha formação eu fiz
física na universidade federal do ceará
que era melhor universidade do meu
estado e meu mestrado eu fiz em física
aplicada à medicina numa área chamada
foto medicina que o uso da luz na área
de saúde tanto para diagnóstico quanto
para terapias essa mestrado eu fiz na
universidade de são paulo na usp e eu
tive a oportunidade de durante o
doutorado pesquisar na maior
universidade do mundo universidade com
400 anos de tradição a harvard medical
school uma escola de medicina de harvard
e lá eu estudei um fenômeno que já tinha
sido observado várias vezes ao longo de
muitos anos
com uma luz conseguiu interagir com o
corpo e tratar do como isso acontecia
mas não havia um mecanismo de ação um
ninguém sabia o que estava acontecendo
passo a passo e ao longo do meu
doutorado
foi exatamente isso que eu pesquisei
como fótons são as partículas de luz são
algumas partículas mais abundantes do
universo consegue interagir com os
neurônios que são nossas células que
sentem tudo nosso corpo desde sentir a
visão audição até a nossa excepção ou
seja o sentido de dor e eu consegui
fazer de tal forma que a luz interage se
com os neurônios e bloquear a
finalização de do criando um tratamento
analgésico sem nenhum efeito colateral
isso chamou muita atenção ea tese
recebeu o prêmio capes de melhores teses
aqui no brasil eu fui convidado para
escrever esse livro que é o handbook of
low level e 0 aqui ou seja o manual de
photomedicine manual de tratamento e meu
mundo se abriu ainda mais porque aqui eu
vi que eu estava fazendo pra dor poderia
ser feito pra outras há outros problemas
outros problemas de saúde com fazendo
este livro teve acesso a todo o
conhecimento de photomedicine nos
últimos 20 anos
e não só isso a um acesso direto aos
cientistas que fizeram essas descobertas
e ainda mais do que isso eu fui
reconhecido por eles
mesmo tendo menos de 30 anos como igual
como alguém que estava criando
conhecimento junto com eles e logo
depois ver uma grande descoberta que é
justamente um método de como fazer com
que a luz entrando dentro do tecido
biológico passando pela pele pela camada
de gordura foi o músculo até chegar os
neurônios do sistema nervoso periférico
que são essas células que sentem tudo o
nosso corpo inclusive a dor
qual era a quantidade exata de energia
para causar a liberação de algumas
substâncias do nosso corpo eu utilizei
uma equação desenvolvida por ice tem e
905 que veio a dar o prêmio nobel a ele
anos depois os conhecimentos de
bioquímica de eric kandel o cientista
austríaco que recebeu o prêmio nobel de
fisiologia no ano 2000 ea copley com
alguns conhecimentos de voto medicina
pra saber exatamente com forma precisa o
quanto de luz era necessário pra pra
liberar de forma precisa alguns remédios
do nosso próprio corpo produz gerando
uma forma completamente não invasiva
completamente sem efeitos colaterais e
sem nenhuma química de fazer com que o
nosso próprio corpo produza os remédios
que nós precisamos e não existe fábrica
de remédio melhor pra você do que o seu
próprio corpo causando essa indução da
nadador dada resposta à dor
a liberação desses remédios só foi
possível criar o que nós chamamos de
remédios digitais
esses remédios digitais são justamente
essa forma de fazer com que a luz
interagindo com cada tipo de célula do
corpo libera substâncias diferentes de
forma que essas substâncias ela serve
para fazer um tratamento e esses
remédios digitais eles conseguem ser
criados e desenvolvidos com custo que
chega a ser 100 vezes menor em um tempo
dez vezes menor do que o desenvolvimento
de um remédio convencional porque grande
parte do que era feito de uma vez por
mês pode ser feito por simulações
computacionais e como nós sabemos isso
tudo que é digitalizado se torna
exponencial e cresce cada vez mais
rápido e pode ser feito em paralelo por
várias pessoas ao redor do mundo
então confira o nosso próximo grande
passo criar uma metodologia que pudesse
fazer com que cientistas ao redor do
mundo juntamente com o nosso
conhecimento e com apoio de outras
entidades
investindo criassem cada vez mais novos
remédios digitais de luz
esses remédios são colocados à
disposição na internet e podem ser feito
o download e aplicados
em qualquer lugar a qualquer momento
basta ter um equipamento que nossa
recepção ea emissão de hoje e nós
desenvolvemos esse equipamento aqui no
brasil com ciência e tecnologia
completamente brasileira
nós já estamos tratando várias pessoas a
cerca de 100 pessoas por semana e esse
número cresce cada vez mais
a facilidade de comunicar isso é como a
facilidade de enviar uma mensagem salvar
de um celular o outro então cientista
brasileiro pode desenvolver um remédio
digital que vai ser usado na europa e
que pode ser usado na áfrica e que a
velocidade para enviar esse remédio é a
velocidade da luz é a velocidade da
condução a desse curso de um local para
o outro do do mundo
a facilidade de se utilizar é a de
colocar um an é de colocar a fonte
emissora de luz em cima do do local do
corpo do paciente e emitir essa radiação
esse mecanismo de ciência aberta que nós
desenvolvemos cria uma comunidade de
cientistas para desenvolver e esse
método é o que permite uma inovação e o
que é inovação isso que tanto se fala ea
gente escuta em todos os locais
a gente pode dividir a gente pode
quadruplicar a inovação da seguinte
forma a inovação é invenção vezes adoção
então pra que algo seja uma inovação
você precisa ter uma atividade inventiva
você precisa criar alguma coisa e nós
temos uma ciência muito criativa você
precisa fazer com que essa tecnologia
seja adotada ou seja que as pessoas o
utilizem
e se você tiver uma invenção sem ter
essa adoção vai ficar nas prateleiras e
gavetas da universidade como
infelizmente nós vemos muito acontecer
então esse método de adoção que nós
criamos permitir um crescimento
exponencial crescimento acelerado do
número de novos remédios digitais de luz
porque eles são feitos podem ser feitos
em qualquer lugar do mundo ao
crescimento do número de terapeutas
habilitados a fazer tratamento
e assim nós poderemos tratar bilhões de
pessoas em todo o mundo isso não estou
falando para daqui a 50 anos eu estou
falando pra essa meta está muito perto
de conseguirmos isso hoje eu tenho
orgulho de dizer pra vocês que nós temos
já utilizando ponto de modulação
tratamento prado prace quatrocci ações
deferidas a derrames cerebrais a vida da
minha vó poderia ter tido uma qualidade
muito mais alta e assim toda minha
família teria ficado muito mais
tranquila mas o que eu posso dizer pra
vocês é uma mensagem de esperança uma
mensagem de que o que nós estamos
fazendo como os cientistas no mundo hoje
permite que a ciência vença a ciência
vem da ignorância e que está sendo
criado um mundo muito melhor para minha
filha que está para nascer agora vai
chegar ao mundo um mundo em que existem
remédios digitais e isso me deixou muito
feliz que eu quero que fique na cabeça
de vocês e não só na cabeça de vocês mas
no coração também é que a ciência no
século passado teve um propósito de
tornar o mundo melhor
nesse século nós faremos com que a
ciência torna um mundo melhor para todos
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]